well good evening and welcome to the
Titanic
we are just like that great ship we are
huge
we are expensive and everybody wants us
to go a lot faster so we will try to do
that tonight
are you ready to go to a real party
for us Oscar Oscar who will win the five
films nominated for Best Picture are
just sit right back and you'll hear a
tale a tale of a giant ship that started
many years ago with an over-budget strip
the boss was a loud director man who
made accountants sick two Studios teamed
up to pay for a three-album flick
everybody got three
it's made a billion dollars now I hope
it's bring some cakes some other films
deserve a break like my giant in three
weeks
my giant in three
but I tan against the story here I've
gotta tip my hat to Gilligan the skipper
to
the propeller guy and the the movie star
the professor and Mary Ann here on
Oscars big
ah good evening it's so great to be back
and miss Gloria Stewart sitting right
here nominated for Titanic what a great
story
I see
sixty-five years ago miss steward
starred in The Invisible Man and she
still work apparently The Invisible Man
is still working he directed as good as
it gets
jack is compulsive the jack is
obsessive-compulsive and Greg is
depressive compulsive obsessive
impulsive depressive this is as good as
it gets
Helen's a waitress Jack as a writer Greg
as a painter he sure ain't a fighter a
waitress a riot or a painter no fighter
this is as good as it gets
but check with your famous shades and
when that smile pearl you know you can
Thomas all just like we're Laker Girls
so eyebrows - Tim you want four cuckoos
in terms of a damn it oh man I love it
we're back and relaxed
forget about Morris attacks
we just mom look I know jack Helen would
you didn't you take a picture of just
just here I'm a clipper Finn we don't
get to the same games thank you so much
ah what a night ladies and gentlemen
Best Actor category is unbelievable
great names in acting Dustin Hoffman
Robert Duvall Peter Fonda of course Jack
Matt Damon must feel like he's playing
on the seniors tour
Maddon been
you are the one
your script was tightened dammit so are
you bummed
you're a hit it's clear to see and you
haven't yet in puberty I go mad at Ben
then in math they're off to the
Governor's Ball while I call to get the
results of my test for cholesterol
Robyn Dustin mini - are all nominated
and it's because of you that a man mad
in bed
la confidentiel be put in quite a show
le confidential but is confusing is the
plat sequential how will I ever know are
there any good guys my mind of losing
nine nominations rules that it's great
it's Mason during a passenger please go
to see it just only late you'll miss the
cup of the libido the Karma - babe
Spacey and DeVito was off he thrilling a
cop who was tomorrow he thinks he's
honesty and when these guys quarrel they
make a killing although this film is
dark elites you choose him cried LA
Confidential you could be the iceberg
tonight
Oh
dah
[ __ ] it's the
my pants are on the floor with a
but there's a dress Monte itself have
Monte it's not showing it's not growing
it's not growing strong this year is in
Monte to show skin Monte's you don't
have to look like Leo man or men so
girls don't be a gig ler everyone can't
be Dirk Diggler dropping your pants is
lots of fun just the way they do in
Washington Monty will never go away
again
what a sight
and stars the way
we'd like to finish by tonight fellas
on behalf of the Academy a billion
people tuning in to see Laila is turning
70 tonight